[Musik]
hallo Leute willkommen zu vlogmas Tag 22
Timo nicht schlafen
o es geht zu Sally jetzt gerade nicht so
richtig wir sind jetzt gerade im Stau
aber auf dem Weg zu Sally oh der Akku
ist g ich bin so aufgeregt ich freue
mich so sehr das ist wirklich für mich
schon das größte vlogmas Highlight dass
ich endlich live das Sally con Valley
sehen kann ich habe m gerade schon im
Auto
geschminkt ich habe noch ein paar
Farbreste im Gesicht vom Haare färben
aber das sollte uns alles nicht
aufhalten heute ist der große Tag bist
du auch aufgeregt extrem ist er nicht
aber es ist okay ich bin für uns beide
aufgeregt oh mein Gott man kann es nicht
sehen aber ich sehe es von
hierkom ich habe soger hofft dass ich
das auch bekomme ah da bin ich da bin
ich da bin ich
cool okay heute ist echt schon für mich
ist heute Weihnachten da kommt das
Schild
sonvelli welc lovely
garden da bin ich da bin
ich herzlich willkommen ich
lieb's das schon nice gemacht ne das ist
schon ein großer Traum von mir dass dass
ich da auch einmal drauf zu sehen binmen
van Leute jetzt sind wir hier bei der
ein bei der einzigen ah hi herzlich
willkommen danke für die Einladung ich
habe das Schild schon draußen gesehen
das ist wirklich der beste Moment also
sein Gesicht daz sehen wir haben es
schon von der Straße aus gesehen ja von
der Bundesstraße aus ja damit auch jeder
mein Gesicht kennt ja ja so wollen wir
rein das
ist das ist ein Stofftier ja oh bist du
süß komm wir nehmen nichtich mal mit
geh wieder
rein komm
rein sieht man ein bisschen beleidigt
ist die Tante backt dir zum zweiten
Geburtstag mein
Baby das ist ja hier
irgendwie also hier ist raspberry nee
hier ist unser produktbüro ach ja klar
natürlich man erkennt ja
sofort hier ist so unser zweites Studio
gerad we vorne ist zwear jetzt fertig
aber wir haben es noch nicht gedreht
aber ich zeig ah danke und hier ist so h
steht auch alles voll ja weil ich gerade
um und hier ist so eigentlich so das
große Büro viele nennen es raspberry
Büro aber eigentlich ein S Büro schon
also ich finde die schon richtig schön
so als komplette Wohnwand ja mega soas
genau wollten wir ne wollten wir mal für
unsere Wohnung haben
genuso cool ja aber jetzt steht halt
vieles gerade rum weil gerade viel Umbau
ist ja
hallo so Sally man kann ja schon sagen
ich habe dich quasi groß gemacht ne gr
gemacht so oft wie ich dich in Videos
erwähnt habe danke dafür also ich habe
dir das hier erstmal möglich gemacht so
danke schön gut dann haben wir das jetzt
erstmal geklärt und jetzt als Gegenzug
backt sie jetzt auch mal mit mir ja ich
habe mir gedacht jetzt gucken wir uns
mal deine backskills an
jahrelang geübt ich habe wirklich sehr
lange geübt ich glaube ich ich also
deine Gäste wie gut sind sie sonst so
gut AR und Troschke war da ja den kann
ich überbieten wer war noch da sturmi
war da sturmi der kann der Backen blchen
di dicker war
da Ross Anthony Tim also ich würde schon
sagen dass du auf
der Skala des Backens schon recht oben
bist also meine Erwartungen sind
hier ja gut das ist eine gute Fallhöhe
dann fangen wir jetzt mal
[Musik]
an hallo herzlich willkommen in S Welt
heute backen
wir und dafür habe ich mir einen ganz
bezaubernden richtig charmanten
wunderschönen Herzallerliebsten Gast zu
Hause eingeladen ich muss jetzt schon
lachen wenn ich dran denke hier ist sie
die einzig und wahre
s
Vanessa und jetzt sind wir auch schon zu
Hause und schneiden gerade den VOG und
jetzt wo ich das alles so sehe ist
einfach so krass dass ich jetzt endlich
mal mit Sally gedreht habe wir waren
schon mal zusammen auf dem OMR und haben
dort drei Cocktails die ballern gemacht
was nie veröffentllich wurde by the way
weil die Aufnahmequalität so schlecht
war dass ich das euch nicht antun wollte
ja und jetzt sitzen wir hier gerade sind
fertig also wir sind ja bei Timos Eltern
wir verbringen hier Weihnachten sind
heute morgen angekommen und dann sind
wir danach zu Sally und jetzt halt
wieder zurückgefahren wir sind fix und
fertig aber ich habe mir was für morgen
überlegt und zwar möchte ich so ein
Pinterest couple Shooting machen ich
wollte halt mal so Weihnacht Bilder
suchen und da ist mir aufgefallen dass
auf Pinterest halt so übelst kitschige
Bilder gibt von couples und ich dachte
das wäre vielleicht für die vorletzte
Folge super witzig wenn wir da halt ja
uns
eigene kappelf Fotos machen das wird
natürlich auch ein Familienprojekt wir
sind ja hier alle gemeinsam und wir
müssen dann auf jeden Fall der die Mama
muss uns dann morgen Filmen damit ihr
das auch seht und der Papa wird die
Fotos machen
Christmas
coule
pictures oh Gott wenn ich das schon sehe
[Applaus]
und cool aus e ich würde nie auf die
Idee kommen solche Bilder mit dir zu
machen aber morgen das ist ein cooles
Foto morgen ist der Tag das finde ich
schon mal richtig gut ich finde das auch
gut das hat so ein bisschen Brandon
waffle oder wie dieser Typ der oh mein
gotttim mit den Lichterketten
fotografiert das Problem ist wir können
uns die ganzen Bilder mit diesem
Tannenbäumen im Haus sparen weil timus
Mama uns immer nicht erlaubt ein
Tannenbaum drin zu haben den haben wir
immer draußen
bombasitei oh Gott Timo das wird echt
schlimm müssen wir morgen auch Feer
shoppen gehen um so ein paar Details zu
z.B so Zuckerstangen das sieht so das
wird richtig gut aber lass doch ein paar
Motive raussuchen dass wir die auch dann
so quasi vielleicht sogar Vergleich
zeigen können W das nicht auch lustig
dass du sagst das haben wir nachgestellt
das ist unsere Version ja finde ich auch
gut ja das ist doch das ist doch eine
gute Idee wir nehmen auf jeden Fall den
Kugel mit mor Wald die Kugel ja die da
der Papa hat die Kugel bestellt was soll
das sein s Spiel s ich geil ja dann zeig
sie jetzt komm vorgestern angemacht sag
bist du verrückt die Macht zerstört die
fliegt überall echt können wir die nicht
einmal sehen
nein okay wie viel Fotos wollen wir
machen h vorgestellt dre F f F ist do
mega viel ich bin für fünf fünf Stück so
ein Foto so ein Fotos schnell gemacht oh
oh das
ist deine Eltern müssen auch mitmachen
und wer macht's besser Challenge wer
macht's besser wir gegen die das ist der
letzte Twist der das Video gebraucht hat
macht euch bereit Leute morgen junge
Menschen gegen alte ne es geht noch
darum wie wie man sich hier einsetzt ne
und Mühe gibt und romantisch in die
Augen guckt weil das das sieht man hier
auf jeden Fall viel ne da könnt ihr euch
viel romantischer in die Augen schauen
weil ihr schaut da in 30 Jahre Liebe wir
halt in SE wir sind da total hinten her
die Bilder sind so kitch ich kann nicht
mehr ab Moderation der Tag war heute
[Musik]
fantastisch jetzt wird noch mehr Holz
reingeworfen das große Finale der
heutigen Folge das jetzt wird noch deam
räumt ja damit es besser aussieht damit
ja es ist ja interior design ihr könnt
bald Timos Mama folgen die gibt euch
dann DIY und interior Tips nee man muss
wirklich sagen ich kenne niemanden der
so schön sein Haus dekoriert für
Weihnachten wie die Mama von Tim das
findet die wieder
toll und da kommt oh der wirft jetzt
hier wieder das TNT
rein die hasenköttel die hasenköttel was
passiert damit jetzt
brennt und dann
geh so Feuerwerk der kleine
pyroman okay wür sagen sehen wir uns in
Abmoderation wir sehen uns gleich vom
Kamin in der
Abmoderation warte warte wir machen wir
machen die den blen Strauß da noch hin
so h das sieht gut
aus ja super das ist das hat den
Unterschied
gemacht
und
damit damit war's das für den heutigen
Vlog ich hoffe euch hat's gefallen danke
s dass ich bei dir sein durfte und ich
freue mich tierisch auf die nächsten
Tage hier im Irrenhaus braunisch tschüss
und bis nächsten
Mal